moi les critiques en tout cas qui sont
les plus blessantes c'est pas forcément
ah mais elle fait si devant les caméras
mais elle a pas honte elle a pas de
parents ça c'est des trucs entre
guillemets que tout les candidats on
reçoit moi c'est beaucoup plus personnel
sur oui mais tu es pas une
femme salut je m'appelle auiel
effectivement j'ai fait frenchy short et
du coup je suis là pour parler un petit
peu de ma vie donc pour commencer bah
mon enfance j'ai une enfance une belle
enfance agréable avec des parents
ouverts tolérant gentil ouvert d'esprit
qui m'ont toujours poussé à être
moi-même qui m'ont jamais mis de bâton
dans les roues donc voilà j'ai une belle
enfance à ce niveau-là j'ai toujours été
très libre d'être comme je voulais donc
je me suis jamais trop posé de questions
quand j'étais jeune jusqu'à mes 10 ans
on va dire fille garçon garçon filles
c'est des choses que je me demandais pas
parce que j'étais libre d'être qui je
voulais donc j'étais juste moi et puis
effectivement quand le temps passe tu
arrives au collège au collège bah du
coup forcément tu dois rentrer dans des
casses tu trouves trouve pas ta place
donc c'est là où tu commences à avoir
des questionnements un peu plus poussés
j'ai commencé à vraiment rejeter de plus
en plus mon corps qui j'étais mon
apparence physique donc je n'allais plus
dans les vestiaires je venais en cours
de sport toujours habillé enfin j'ai
vraiment fait un rejet complet de de
moi-même jusqu'à effectivement que
j'arrive à à mes 18 ans donc à ma
majorité où j'ai pu entamer les
démarches pour changer moi à 15 ans j'ai
mis un mot sur ce que je ce que je ce
que j'étais en fait tout simplement et à
15 ans je suis tombée sur un article qui
parlait de la transidentité donc de ce
que c'était je sais plus exactement quel
était l'article mais en tout cas j'ai lu
l'article et ça fait vraiment eff fait
comme une révélation où je me suis dit
ah ok en fait c'est ça c'est ce que tu
es c'est pour ça que tu ressens ça c'est
pour ça que tu es pas à ta place et tout
s complètement éclairci je m'en rappelle
j'ai appelé ma ma mère en lui disant
maman je viens de tomber sur ça j'ai
compris c'est ça donc ma mère je le dis
directement à mes 15 ans et après j'ai
attendu quand même un petit peu parce
qu'à l'époque j'avais un un copain
c'était mon premier amour avec qui
j'étais et je savais qu'and tu une
transition i ça allait signer la fin bah
notre de notre relation ensemble donc du
coup c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai repoussé
un petit peu le le commencement des
démarches pour ma transition et
effectivement après à mes 18 ans j'ai
sauté le pas j'ai enlevé tout ce qui
pouvit être négatif autour de moi et
puis je me suis lancé pour devenir qui
j'étais réellement alors j'ai la chance
d'avoir été toujours très bien entouré
voilà autant au niveau de ma famille que
de mes amis donc tout le monde a été
très compréhensif tout le monde a été
très aimant avec moi j'ai jamais eu de
rejet mes parents forcément c'est un
petit peu compliqué au début même si
c'est des parents ouverts tolérants
quand ça concerne ton enfant euh c'est
toujours un petit peu compliqué c'est
une forme de de deuil puisque tu mets un
enfant au monde cet enfant change
physiquement change d'identité change
d'état civil donc bien que mes parents
soient très compréhensifs faut aussi se
mettre à la place des parents et c'est
vrai que ça a été voilà un peu compliqué
il aura fallu un petit temps
d'adaptation mais au final voilà ils
sont rapidement été avec moi ils m'ont
toujours soutenu ils m'ont toujours
accompagné dans toutes mes démarches euh
voilà ils ont été là vraiment à 100 % de
A à Z dans ma transition mes amis c'est
pareil j'ai jamais perdu d'amis toutes
les personnes qui m'entouraient avant
sont encore mes amis à l'heure actuelle
j'ai toujours été bien entouré sélective
et voilà je donne pas mon amitié à
n'importe qui donc c'est vrai que à ce
niveau-là j'ai vraiment de la chance de
d'avoir perdu personne dans mon cercle
privé par rapport à ma transition du
coup j'ai sauté le pas réellement en
commençant les démarches donc du coup à
ma majorité donc je devais avoir un peu
plus de 18 ans j'ai entre 18 et 19 ans
je sais pas exactement mais entre sur
cette année-là j'avais de l'appréhension
oui et non la seule appréhension que
j'avais c'est que du coup ça allait
mettre fin à la que j'avais avec mon
excomagnon donc ça c'est une première
appréhension que j'avais mais sur le
point de vue personnel voilà quand j'ai
fait ma transition c'est parce que
j'étais arrivé à un stade de non retour
c'était pas une question de je veux
ressembler à à si ou à ça c'est une
question de vie ou de mort ça ça devient
des triples quand tu es pas dans le bon
corps tu es pas dans le bon corps la
disphorie de genre c'est pas une partie
de plaisir on fait pas ça pour le fun
c'est pas quelque chose de tendance
c'est vraiment vicéral c'est tu te
regardes dans le miroir tu te dégoûtes
tu te supportes plus tu envie de
t'arracher la peau et du coup je suis
arrivé à un stade où je me suis dit bah
soit tu deviens quiit tuer tu vis ta vie
en est en étant la femme que tu es soit
tu décides de rester comme tu es mais tu
vas finir par [__] ta vie en l'air
enfin clairement te te tuer au sens
propre du terme parce que tu tu peux pas
vivre toute ta vie dans un corps qui ne
qui te correspond pas et ça a vraiment
été le déclic de ça a été pour me sauver
en fait si j'ai fait cette transition ça
a été vraiment pour sauver ma vie et
pour pouvoir continuer de vivre très
clairement au niveau des étapes dans une
transition alors ça je le dis tout le
temps et c'est super important il y a
pas de bonne ou de mauvaise transition
moi la transition que je l'ai faite je
l'ai faite parce que c'est ma manière de
voir les choses mais toute transition
est ok il y a pas de format il y a pas
de schéma il y a pas un code à suivre le
tout c'est de faire les choses en bonne
uniforme pour toi-même et que ça te
ressemble sur le point de vue
administratif le changement d'état civil
que j'ai fait alors ça en tout premier
lieu avant même je crois les hormones
j'avais dû à peine commencer les
hormones euh je su directement monté mon
mon mon dossier pour changer du coup euh
mon genre mon état civil au sens propre
du terme sur les papiers pour pouvoir
changer bah du coup carte Vitale carte
d'identité permis de conduire ça je l'ai
fait vraiment au début vraiment j'avais
dû commencer les hormones depuis à peine
un mois c'est la première chose que j'ai
faite parce que je voulais pas être
embêté dans mes démarches pour chercher
du travail parce que pour avoir de
l'argent pour faire des opérations faut
travailler pour travailler la société
c'est un peu compliqué donc c'est
vraiment la première chose que j'ai
faite c'est de mettre à jour mes papiers
donc du coup j'ai monté un dossier seul
il y en a qui prennent des avocats moi
je l'ai fait seul donc ça m'a pris un
bon temps j'ai fait un bon gros dossier
de 40 pages que j'ai envoyé au tribunal
de grande instance et j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance parce que mon dossier a été
accepté en 15 jours donc en un mois euh
mon identité juridiquement a été
complètement changée j'ai vu une
psychothérapeute qui m'a fait une
attestation qui m'a permis d'aller voir
une endocrinologue cette endocrinologue
là m'a fait une ordonnance qui m'a
permis d'aller à la pharmacie récupérer
mes hormones 2 ans de traitement
hormonal avant de passer par la case
chirurgie parce que je voulais que mon
corps se féminise naturellement à
maximum après voilà comme je le dis
aussi beaucoup les hormones c'est pas
magique euh tu te transformes pas du
jour au lendemain en un clinquement de
doigt ça féminise ton apparence mais ça
ne te transforme pas donc c'est vrai que
la case chirurgie pour moi en tout cas
était super importante donc du coup au
bout de 2 ans d'hormones j'ai commencé
en refaisant ma poitrine c'est la
première chose que j'ai faite donc du
coup j'avais une petite poitrine qui
avait poussé avec les hormones sur la
même année je crois que j'en ai fait
plusieurs ensuite j'ai fait j'ai
commencé la féminisation de mon visage
donc j'ai fait euh féminiser le haut de
mon visage en premier donc j'ai limé un
peu les bosses frontal euh les EOS du
front l'arcade sourcilière euh j'ai fait
ma mâchoire donc du coup affiner le côté
carré de ma mâchoire affiner mon menton
ensuite j'ai fini par refaire du coup
mon nez et du coup en dernière opération
celle que j'ai faite la vaginoplastie
qui a été faite il y a 3 ans donc du
coup entre le début de ma transition et
comment je suis aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ça fait ça va faire 6 7 ans mais ma
transition a été finie à 3 ans donc du
coup je pense qu'en tout j'ai dû prendre
tris 3 années tris bonnes années pour
pour tout faire une fois euh la
transition terminée en tout cas moi ce
que j'ai fait personn ement forcément je
me sens beaucoup mieux puisque tu te
regardes dans un corps qui te correspond
tu te sens en adéquation physiquement et
mentalement donc du coup c'est vrai que
ça fait du bien c'est un grand
soulagement après je pense qu'il y a
toujours une quête un peu éternelle chez
les femmes trans de de cette féminité on
a la dysphorie de genre qui même en
ayant fait la chirurgie même en ayant
fait 1 une opération reste présente
c'est vraiment cette sensation de se
regarder dans un miroir et de
constamment avoir l'impression encore de
de voir des traits masculins de voir un
garçon et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très personnel aux femmes trans et
celles qui verront comprendront moi
personnellement encore à l'heure
actuelle ça m'arrive de me regarder dans
le miroir et de me dire ah mais non mais
ça non ça c'est pas bien mais ça tu
ressembles à un garçon etci et ça on est
très dur avec nous-mêm c'est pour ça que
la chirurgie c'est pas juste esthétique
chez chez les personnes trans c'est
vraiment réparateur autant physiquement
que mentalement et c'est pour nous une
manière de gommer les traits ce qui nous
crée en tout cas de la dysphorie au
quotidien mais c'est vrai que c'est un
combat éternel qu'on aura avec notre
apparence avec l'acceptation de soi bien
qu'aujourd'hui je sois très bien dans ma
peau je sois très contente que je m'aime
et que je revendique ce message dans ma
vie tous les jours mais c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas nier les personnes trans disvit
jusqu'à la fin de ta vie elle y sera il
y a des jours où vraiment tu te regardes
dans un miroir tu te dégoûtes et tu as
pas envie de sortir de chez toi une fois
ma transition terminée au niveau de mon
entourage j'ai pas forcément
l'impression que le regard avait changé
si ce n'est qu' me disait ah ça te va
bien ah tu es plus jolie ah c'est cool
je suis contente pour toi mais euh les
personnes proches de mon entourage m'en
suis vu du début à la fin donc ils ont
vu l'évolution petit à petit donc il y a
pas eu de de changement radical quand
ils m'ont vu ils m'ont pas vu 6 ans
après sans ne jamais m'avoir
faitquentter donc non franchement mais
mon entourage n'a jamais été choqué
alors si ce n'est le postopératoire ou
tu es très gonflé ou tu as une tête un
peu diforme donc ça peut être un petit
peu choquant mais sur le résultat final
autant mes amis que ma famille ont
toujours été très contents personne a
été choqué c'est vrai que en tout cas je
pense que c'est pour beaucoup de
personnes trans comme ça tes proches
sont toujours non mais fais pas plus tu
bien comme ça je pense qu'on veut
toujours un petit peu nous nous limiter
dans dans ce plus plus plus qu'on veut
toujours après voilà c'est pour notre
bien-être faut aussi comprendre que le
la chirurgie c'est pas un caprice chez
les femmes trans c'est vraiment une
thérapie et ça je le redis ça peut
paraître fou mais faire de la chirurgie
quand tu es une femme transgenre en tout
cas c'est vraiment une thérapie
psychologique et ça te permet d'aller
mieux et voilà heureusement que la
chirurgie existe en tout cas pour nous
psychologiquement c'est quelque chose
qui nous a énormément aidé euh moi au
niveau des relations amoureuses
personnellement j'ai eu que des longues
relations donc du coup quand j'ai
commencé ma transition j'ai rencontré un
garçon avec qui je suis resté 2 ans
j'avais pas encore fait de chirurgie
rien du tout donc du coup voilà il m'a
pris entre guillemets comme j'étais j'ai
une relation de 2 ans avec lui à la
suite de quoi moi j'ai fait toutes mes
opérations et là où j'ai rencontré mon
bah mon dernier copain qui est pour moi
en tout cas le grand amour de ma vie
avec qui je suis restée 2 ans qui bah là
c'était vraiment mon
premier ma première relation où vraiment
j'étais 100 % moi-même avec avec un
homme qui m'accepit à 100 % pour la
femme que j'étais donc il y avait
quelque chose de très très thérapeutique
aussi de sortir avec un homme qui
t'accepte qui a conscience de ton passé
qui te juge pas qui te soutient c'est
quelque chose de super important quand
tu es une femme trans trouver l'amour
c'est pas une tâche facile c'est très
compliqué parce que les hommes ont
encore beaucoup de mentalités fermé en
se disant mais si je sors avec une femme
trans qu'est-ce que je suis est-ce que
ça fait de moins bisexuel est-ce que
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui est
encore compliqué je me tue à le dire
jour jour jour jour jour après jour un
homme hétérosexuel qui sort avec une
femme transgre reste un homme
hétérosexuel parce qu'il sort avec une
femme le passé c'est le passé je veux
dire voilà chaque femme a son passé et
ça ne change en rien la sexualité d'un
homme de sortir avec une femme
transgenre et voilà ma première relation
en tout cas qui a vraiment compté pour
moi ça a été ma dernière relation où
vraiment ça m'a beaucoup apporté ça m'a
permis de me sentir vraiment bien en
tant que femme j'avais ce quotidien
métro boulot dodo une vie une vie bien
rangée et euh j'ai mis fin à cette
relation parce que voilà j'avais un
besoin personnel de de liberté de vivre
et de de de profiter en fait de toutes
mes années de bataille et c'est vrai que
cette relation m'enfermer trop mais euh
le regard des hommes change
effectivement au fur et à mesure de ta
transition au fur et à mesure des étapes
notamment la vaginoplastie ou forcément
ce que tu as entre les jambes change
beaucoup de choses par rapport au regard
des hommes moi dès le départ en tout cas
d'une relation sérieuse je n'ai jamais
été en couple ou je n'ai jamais
fréquenté un garçon sur de la longue
durée sans lui avoir dit que j'étais une
femme trans parce que voilà tu t'ouvres
intimement tu construis quelque chose
avec la personne et moi en tout cas je
veux pas construire quelque chose basé
sur un mensonge après c'est vrai que les
relations sexuelles voilà c'est autre
chose je veux dire quand tu rencontres
un garçon en soirée tu as bu de l'alcool
voilà c'est un autre contexte tu sais
que la personne tu vas pas forcément la
revoir mais en tout cas avoir une
relation sérieuse pour moi c'est
inconcevable personnellement de bâtir
une relation de m'ouvrir à quelqu'un
sans qu'il ait conscience du plus gros
détail me concernant rechercher du
travail en tant que femme transgenre
honnêtement c'est un peu un peu cru ce
que je vais dire mais ça va clairement
dépendre de ton sis passing le SIS
passing en gros pour traduire ça plus
pédagogiquement c'est en gros
l'apparence que tu as moins les gens se
rendent compte que tu es une femme trans
plus tu auras de facilité à trouver du
travail et ça je trouve ça dégueulasse
mais malheureusement c'est la
vérité plus ton physique passe comme
n'importe quelle femme moins tu auras de
problème à trouver du boulot et la
discrimination aujourd'hui au niveau des
trans elle y est encore énormément et
moi je sais que si j'ai jamais eu de
problèm à trouver du travail ça a été
notamment parce que mes employeurs n'ont
jamais tilté forcément que j'étais une
femme trans et je sais que d'autres amis
ou d'autres personnes que je connais qui
sont en début de transition qui
cherchent du travail ou forcément je
veux dire comme moi quand on prend
physiquement il y a 6 ans en arrière euh
voilà c'est tu es pas la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui et ben ces personnes-là
vont avoir du mal à trouver les
employeurs vont avoir du mal à assumer
qu'une employé soit une femme trans vont
avoir du mal à assumer le regard des
clients enfin c'est quelque chose de
très compliqué aujourd'hui de s'intégrer
en tant que femme trans dans la société
ça se démocratise en tout cas moi c'est
aussi pour ça que je le revendique c'est
de de décomplexer les mentalités sur la
transidentité mais oui aujourd'hui
encore bientôt 2024 quand tu es une
femme trans et que les gens s'en rendent
compte B on te discrimine parce qu'on va
pas forcément assumer de te prendre
comme comme employé avant de faire Frany
SH du coup bah je faisais comme
n'importe quel jeune en tout cas
beaucoup j'allais un peu là où je
pouvais gagner de l'argent donc j'ai
travaillé dans les assurances j'ai
travaillé dans le service aprèsvente de
la téléphonie j'ai été vendeuse en
différentes boutiques enfin je
travaillais tout simplement pour gagner
de l'argent et vivre et du coup j'ai
arrêté de travailler je crois 2 mois
avant le tournage du coup j'avais mis
fin mon dernier emploi et à la suite de
quoi ben je suis partie faire frenchsh
et aujourd'hui j'en suis ici French SH
ça s'est fait franchement c'est vraiment
le destin qui m'a ramené à frenchy SH
j'avais fait à la base un casting pour
une autre émission de
télééralité ma personnalité était trop
flamboyante trop extravertie j'étais
trop trop trop et c'était compliqué de
me mettre sur une chaîne de la TNT à 18h
ou 19h et on avait pas envie entre
guillemets de prendre ma personnalité de
la brimer et de devoir me canaliser donc
on m'a dit écoute on t'adore mais il y a
quelque chose qui arrive et je pense que
ça va être parfait pour toi et c'est
comme ça en fait que j'atterteris dans
fren short dès que le casting a été
officiel on m'a appelé on m'a dit RAL
c'est ton tour tu pars Freny short bah
c'est tout simplement la version
française de Jordi short jers Shore Rio
Shore il en existe plein de versions
donc de la famille des short c'est
globalement les plus gros féard donc
pour nous de France réuni dans une villa
où on fait la fête mais hormi ça c'est
aussi 10 personnes euh très très
différente avec une identité de genre
avec une sexualité avec des couleurs de
peau avec des corpulences c'est un
casting très inclusive et on est là pour
faire la fête pour s'amuser pour pas se
prendre la tête et pour décomplexer les
mentalités l'appréhension que j'aurais
pu avoir avant d'arriver dans dans la
villa ça pouvait être effectivement le
fait qu'à un moment j'allais annoncer
que j'étais une femme trans donc du coup
la production était au courant mais pas
les candidats donc du coup j'ai dû
l'annoncer de moi-même au bout d'un
moment je me suis dit de toute manière
je suis comme je suis qu'on ne m'imme ou
qu'on ne mime pas j'ai pas changé à ma
personne mais en tout cas effectivement
ce détail sur ma transidentité c'était
quelque chose qui pouvait un petit peu
me me chifonner en effet sur le retour
que les candidats allaient avoir du coup
mon coming out je l'ai fait il me semble
au bout de quelques jours très
rapidement c'est dans l'épisode 2 parce
que je me rapprochais des garçons et je
voulais pas que ça aille plus loin parce
que oui effectivement il y a des scènes
de sexualité et je voulais pas que ces
scènes soient faites avec des hommes qui
n'ai pas conscience de qui je suis déjà
de un parce que Ben pour être réglot et
pour être honnête avec eux j'avais
besoin de le dire et puis le but aussi
pour moi c'était de revendiquer de faire
passer un message à travers cette
émission c'est que les femmes trans sont
comme n'importe quelle femme elles ont
une vie tout à fait normale elles
fréquentent n'importe quel homme c'est
pas quelque chose de tabou c'est quelque
chose qui doit se démocratiser c'est
quelque chose qui doit devenir banal et
arrêter d'en faire tout un Pat à caisse
autour de la transidentité donc pour moi
le dire euh c'était de un euh de dire je
suis une femme trans je fais exactement
la même chose que toutes les autres
femmes de cette vie-là il y a aucune
différence et c'est comme ça qu'on
devrait vivre dans la société de tous
les jours la réaction des candidats a
été très bonne honnêtement il y a eu que
des bons retours ça n'a rien changé ça a
vraiment été un non événement et c'est
pour ça que on parle beaucoup de mon
histoire de mon coming out mais en fait
c'est absolument pas ce qui me définit
dans l'émission j'ai jamais été Riel la
femme trans je suis
Riel candidate de Freny SH et une femme
trans mais ma trans identité c'est pas
ce qui me définit dans l'émission et du
coup tous les retours étaient était
positif c'est un non événement les
garçons ça n'a rien changé les filles ça
n'a rien changé et c'est un très très
bel exemple de coming out et une très
belle leçon de morale pour beaucoup de
personnes que à la télé sur une
plateforme dans une émission de
téléréalité française une femme trans
soit clairement inclu et que tout le
monde en ait rien à faire j'avais
quelques proches autour de moi quelques
amis à qui je nen avais pas parlé
puisque je les ai rencontré dans un
contexte professionnel à une époque où
je sortais avec mon ex qui lui ne
voulait pas que ça sche donc j'étais
très privé sur mon passé et du coup bah
elles l'ont apprise effectivement
pendant l'émission je leur ai envoyé un
message le jour même de la diffusion je
leur ai dit bon vous allez peut-être
comprendre quelque chose dans l'émission
que je vous ai pas dit et au final voilà
j'avais un peu d'appréhension parce
qu'elles ont des croyances des opinions
très différentes du mien et au final
tout s'est bien passé aucun rejet
honnêtement mes amis sont en or avant
l'émission personnellement je m'étais
mise aucune barrière parce que je ne me
mets aucune barrière dans la vie de tous
les jours que je vis le moment présent
donc je ne fais jamais de plan sur la
comète je vais là où je vais je me
laisse vivre et je fais les choses 100 %
naturellement et non je me suis dit tu
vas tu vas toi-même tu vas faire ce que
tu as à faire comme tu aurais fait dans
ta vie tous les jours et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé vivre
entouré de caméra toute la journée c'est
c'est un contexte qui change quand c'est
une première fois l'avantage qu'on avait
aussi c'est que c'était beaucoup de
caméras fixes donc en fait on était pas
omnibulé par les caméras moi honnêtement
je pense qu'au bout d'une heure les
caméras je les avais complètement oublié
on se laisse porter on est 10 potes
entre nous en train de faire la fête
s'amuser tous ensemble et dans le
contexte des caméras est vite oublié
après c'est sûr quand c'est un tournage
bah c'est une aventure une aventure
particulière de vivre ce côté caméra
interview c'est c'est un monde c'est une
sphère quand tu es en tournage mais en
tout cas le tournage de French short
c'était une sphère très très belle très
positive et honnêtement que ce soit avec
les candidats ou les équipes il s'est
vraiment passé une belle histoire
d'amour entre nous et honnêtement 10/ 10
refire je ferai exactement la même chose
j'ai aucun regret quand à fren tshir
j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire j'étais
fidèle à moi-même j'ai fait passer mes
messages donc je suis très contente de
ce que j'ai pu faire la cohabitation
avec des personnes que tu connais pas
peut être un peu compliqué moi
personnellement c'est vrai que je
m'adapte je suis je suis une bonne
vivante je me prends pas la tête donc
personnellement ça allait après c'est
sûr que quand on est 10 avec des
personnalités différentes tous des forts
caractères enfermés dans un contexte
particulier c'est vrai que tout est
décuplé les émotions les sentiments donc
tu peux avoir la tête qui tourne un
petit peu parfois tu peux t'énerver pour
des petites choses que en temps normal
tu laisserais passer mais honnêtement
entre nous ça s'est très bien passé on
est une belle famille les fren on est 10
candidats qui avont tous très bien
matchés ensemble et personnellement pour
ce tournage la cohabitation moi elle
s'est très bien passé et si c'est à
refaire je le referai
également non fren tshar ça a été ma
première télé j'avais jamais fait de
télé j'étais absolument pas dans le
monde audiovisuel ne ser que mê de faire
des shootings photos parler devant une
caméra je n'avais jamais fait ça de ma
vie donc non ça a étit ça était le grand
schlem pour moi je suis vraiment partie
dans cette nouvelle expérience en tant
que novice à 100 %. c'est une émission
trage pour la France on va dire que
c'est plus trash que ce qu'on a
l'habitude de voir dans une téléréalité
habituelle en France cette émission ça
fait 15 ans qu'elle existe dans le monde
entier donc c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau non plus il a la sexualité où il
y a des embrouilles plus poussés on nous
voit boire ver un verre d'alcool alors
que c'est pas flouté mais au final ce
qu'on fait c'est la vie de tous les
jours on entre pote on s'éclate on fait
la fête et je pense pas que ce soit
trash je pense que c'est juste un reflet
de la société alors attention je mets
pas tout le monde dans le même panier on
n'est pas des ambassadeurs quoi que ce
soit fren on ne dit pas que tout le
monde doit être comme nous mais en tout
cas je pense qu'on fait partie de la
sphère festif et que tous les gens qui
aiment faire la fête qui aiment s'amuser
se reconnaissent dans French short donc
c'est trage sans être rage c'est trage
pour la France mais je pense que ça va
rentrer dans les leurs petit à petit et
les gens adorent Fry SH parce que je
pense que tout le monde se reconnaît
quelques part dans cette émission euh
interdit dans la villa bah déjà la
drogue ça c'est catégorique je pense que
c'est évident hein ça c'est catégorique
hors de question tout ce qui est injure
homophobie racisme
transphobie propos sur X ou Y raison
voilà tout propos dénigrant sur une
personne c'est hors de question c'est
dehors aussi donc voilà on a la chance
d'être des candidats très respectueux
donc du coup ça s'est très bien passé de
ce côté-là il jamais de problème après
en chose interdite non ça a été ça a été
ça il faut pas que ce soit dans les
excès en fait tout ce qui se fait voilà
il faut qu'on profite qu'on fasse la
fête mais il faut quand même que ça
reste avec de la bienveillance même
quand il y a de l'alcool on est quand
même encadré on nous laisse pas avec 15
bouteilles de vot cas à disposition on
est encadré le but c'est qu'on soit même
quand on boit dans un état ok on fait un
peu la fête on est festif mais ça reste
quand même cordial le but c'est jamais
de tomber dans l'excès donc tout était
autorisé mais jamais dans l'excès
toujours avec bienveillance et toujours
encadré c'est important de le dire avant
l'émission non j'avais pas j'étais pas
du tout dans le milieu honnêtement je
connaissais pas de enfin de vue de nom
et cetera oui mais personnellement
j'avais pas du tout d'amis proches dans
le milieu de la télérréalité euh
aujourd'hui j'en côtois pas forcément
plus honnêtement on est on est très
entre nous les frchur on est une petite
sexe on aime bien être entre nous garder
notre esprit French short donc c'est
vrai qu'on ne s'éparpie pas partout avec
n'importe qui on on reste en entre
famill French short maintenant j'ai
quelques enfin je parle à quelques
personnes de télé on s'échange des
messages mais ça reste ça reste
sympathique mais je suis pas en il y a
pas de choses parti titulair avec des
candidats et je suis très bien comme ça
les critiques sur les réseaux par
rapport à frenchsh bah honnêtement je
pense que ce soit moi ou mes neuf autres
collègues d'émission on est tous ok sur
le fait que c'est normal enfin on s'y
attendait c'est une émission qui change
il y a des choses diffusé qui ne sont
pas diffusables on est des personnes
assumées libérées très excentriqu donc
la critique moi personnellement je
l'accepte et c'est ce que je dis tout le
temps vous pouvez ne pas aimer on
l'accepte mais il faut que ça reste dans
le respect je peux accepter la non
acceptation mais pas le manque de
respect donc chacun droit voir son point
de vue et fren short de toute manère
c'est pas une émission qui est qui est
pour tout le monde comme je dis souvent
quand tu vas dans un magasin de
vêtements tu vas pour acheter tes
vêtements bah quand tu regardes Freny
short il va pour regarder des choses en
particulière un programme qui change
donc voilà faut pas s'étonner quand on
regarde fr cher on sait ce qu'on ce
qu'on va trouver là-bas moi
personnellement les critique forcément
on les a fait x 10 par rapport aux
autres candidats je suis une femme trans
donc déjà je pars avec une balle dans le
pied au niveau de la société en France
en plus de ça je suis une femme assumée
sexuellement j'assume ce que je fais
j'ai des propos très crus très C voilà
je suis une personne très assumée de A à
Z donc forcément que sur les réseaux
moins les critiques ça a fusé maintenant
au début je regardais beaucoup parce que
c'est fun ça commence l'émission parle
de toi il y a un côté un peu trépident
mais je pense qu'au bout de du du 2e
jour de diffusion enin 24 heures après
la diffusion du premier épisode j'ai
commencé à arrêter de regarder je
trouvais pas ça constructif remettre en
question qui je suis personnellement je
sais qui je suis je suis bien dans mes
basques donc j'ai la chance d'avoir la
tête bien sur les épaules parce que
c'est vrai que ça peut faire un peu mal
sometimes mais mais je suis bien je suis
avec tout ce qui se passe et les
critiques ça me passe audessus moi les
critiques en tout cas qui sont les plus
blessantes c'est pas forcément ah mais
elle fait si devant les caméras mais
elle a pas honte elle a pas de parents
ça c'est des trucs entre guillemets que
tous les candidats ont reçoit moi c'est
beaucoup plus personnel sur oui mais tu
es pas une femme ah mais regarde elle
mais n non mais ils ont pas honte les
hommes de fréquenter ça et tes
chromosomes ils sont comme ça ou alors
les commentaires on va clment m'appeler
monsieur il on me met genre par
excellence ça c'est des commentaires pas
qui me touchent mais qui m'énervent plus
pour l'être humain de manière générale
pour les les personnes qui peuvent pas
forcément sentir bien dans leur peau qui
essayent de s'accepter et qui voient ce
genre de débilité sur les réseaux en
fait je trouve ça bête je trouve ça
futile et puis en attendant voilà c'est
c'est comme ça quand tu t'assumes quand
tu es quit tu es ça dérange et puis si
si ça dérangeait pas c'est que les
forriel n'auraiit pas fonctionné donc je
suis blindé vous pouvez y aller euh mes
proches non je les laisse un maximum en
dehors de tout ça ils savent les
missions ils savent le concept
maintenant mes parents sont pas en jouer
à l'idée que je fasse cette émission
voilà c'est très sexuel je me montre
tout le monde sait que je suis comme ça
dans la vie tous les jours après voilà
mes parents sont pas forcément hyper
contents que j'ai fait cette émission
maintenant ils acceptent ils sont avec
moi ils me soutiennent et ils acceptent
ma décision comme n'importe quel parent
qui soutient son enfant
inconditionnellement c'est vrai que le
changement de vie a été enfin de vie le
changement de statut entre guillemets de
personne inconnu à personne publique a
été radical c'est un changement de vie
c'est quelque chose qui est encore très
irréaliste pour moi personnellement
parce que j'ai l'impression d'être juste
moi-même et de m'amuser comme je fais
dans la vie de tous les jours je réalise
pas forcément l'impact qu'il y a quand
on m'appelle pour faire des plateaux des
choses comme ça forcément je suis
toujours j'ai toujours ce côté waouh
j'intéresse des personnes qui je suis
intéresse et captive l'attention et du
coup je trouve ça bah pour ma part
flatteur surtout que je revendique
beaucoup de choses dans cette émission
donc que ce que je revendique soit
accepté que les gens adhèrent avec
ourriel bah moi ça me fait plaisir et et
franchement c'est que du c'est que du
positif c'est sûr quand tu sors dans la
rue qu'on te reconnaî moi c'est toujours
un peu surprenant parce qu'on me connaît
intimement de par l'émission mais moi je
connais pas forcément les personnes qui
est en face donc c'est un changement de
vie qui est qui est en train de se faire
mais je suis contente parce que ça se
fait à ma manière avec des choses qui me
ressemblent et j'ai une communauté qui
est très très réaliste avec qui je suis
qui est très comme moi donc franchement
je suis contente de tout et je fais
passer des messages les messages sont
reçus donc c'est le principal jusqu'à
maintenant que ce soit sur les plateaux
télé ou dans la rue c'est que de la
bienveillance voilà toutes les
interviews les plateaux que j'ai pu
faire ça a toujours été très cordial
très amical très gentil avec des bonnes
intentions pour le moment donc j'ai de
la chance dans la rue pareil les gens
qui me connaissent c'est toujours
positif après voilà les gens sont plus
crus sur les réseaux qu'en face on sait
que c'est plus compliqué de venir dire
en face d'une personne ce qu'on pense
d'elle maintenant je suis pas la BRI que
ça arrive j'ai toujours cette petite
oreille attentive de me dire attention
où tu vas attention ce que tu fais
surtout toi tu es exposé encore plus à à
des potentiellagression physique ou
verbal mais pour le moment je touche du
bois tout va bien et j'espère que ça
continuera comme ça c'est vrai que au
niveau du rôle social que je peux avoir
et surtout dû à l'impact de l'émission
c'est quelque chose qui me fait plaisir
entre guillemets parce que moi je sais
que je revendique des valeurs qui me
correspondent et peu importe ce qu'on
dit sur les réseaux je suis quelqu'un
d'éduqué qui a des principes des valeurs
je sais ce que je fais j'ai la tête sur
les épaules donc je sais que si des
personnes s'identifient à moi es
s'identifient à une personne en tout cas
scinene d'esprit qui pourra que les
aiguiller dans dans le bon sens du terme
après comme je le dis moi je veux pas
qu'on me mette sur le dos toute la
responsabilité du monde je suis pas
porte-parole de tout le monde si les
gens m'apprécient tant mieux si des
personnes m'apprécient pas je peux
comprendre moi je suis pas là en train
de dire je représente la communité LGBT
vous devez faire comme moi pas du tout
chacun a le droit de faire ce qu'il veut
dans sa vie moi j'accepte le choix de
tout le monde mais en tout cas ça me
fait plaisir dans une émission vue par
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui qui
est pas forcément destiné à une
communauté forcément open puisque tout
le monde regarde cette émission c'est
pas forcément une communauté cuir LGBT
ou autre bah que mon personnage que qui
je suis que la manière que j'ai d'être
ressorte et est apprécié c'est une belle
une belle revanche sur la vie de sortir
du lot de tout ça et que mes valeurs et
qui je suis je les emmène avec moi
jusqu'au bout et j'espère que je les
emmènerai le plus haut possible depuis
la fin de l'émission j'ai pas eu
d'autres proposition de télé honnêtement
bah en plus la diffusion c'était je
parle de ça comme ça faisait longtemps
mais ça fait vraiment 15 jours et demi
que ça a commencé 3 semaines bientôt
donc c'est récent donc des plateaux des
ITV des choses comme ça ben je les ai
faites après en terme de télé non après
je sais pas si tout le monde assume la
personne ou rielle parce qu'il faut y
aller moi Dee manère je su suis une
fidèle à Frany SH et on espère tous
qu'un jour on puisse repartir faire une
autre saison donc pour le moment voilà
et pas plus moi personnellement je veux
continuer sur cette lancée j'ai pas
envie en tout cas de tomber dans ce
cliché des personnes de télé qui font
des choses similaires j'ai envie de
faire des choses différentes je veux
continuer
à inculquer les valeurs en tout cas que
moi j'estime inculquer en terme de
libération du corps de l'esprit de la
femme de l'être humain je veux faire des
choses constructives je veux faire des
des choses qui sont en ma faveur et
j'espère pouvoir allier l'audiovisuel
avec ma mentalité avec ce que je pense
avec mes valeurs et vraiment faire
quelque chose de constructif et positif
j'ai pas de projet en particulier pour
l'instant mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
si je fais des choses ce sera que des
choses
qualitatives pour les jeunes qui se
posent des questions sur qui ils sont
sur leur identité de genre sur leur
sexualité sur peu importe la raison
écoutez-vous faites les choses comme bon
vous semble ne vous précipitez pas non
plus c'est un conseil que je donne
prenez le temps de peser le pour et le
compte de vous entourer d'être d'être
sûr de faire les choses comme il le faut
voilà quoi qu'il arrive quand tu es
destiné à faire quelque chose ou quand
ta vie est destinée à avoir telle ou
telle chose qui arrive ça arrivera donc
crois en toi va au bout de tes rêves ne
baisse surtout jamais les bras et
surtout écoute-toi personnellement et ne
laisse jamais l'invie des autres
impacter qui tu es ou ce que tu veux
faire dans la vie et quoi qu'il en soit
tu arrives seul sur cette terre tu
repartiras seul donc quand tu repars
d'ici il faut que tu a vécu ta meilleure
vie